[Music]
i am jonathan burke the apg professor of
finance at the graduate school of
business at stanford university
and i'm jules van binsbergen the nippon
life professor in finance at the wharton
school at the university of pennsylvania
join us on a journey as we explore the
science and strategy of better decision
making today we will consider an
important business decision the decision
about whether to buy a good business
whether you're a sole proprietor think
of buying an established small business
or a conglomerate concerning the
decision to buy up a new brand or
starting a new division
the same question needs to be answered
what is a good business to buy to make
this decision concrete let's consider a
business purchasing decision most of us
make buying stock in a public company
how do you put together a good stock
portfolio which stocks are good buys and
which ones are not so as usual last week
i was talking to one of my golf buddies
and he was telling me what a great stock
i pick every year's
he's never ever told me about any bad
investments he's made but he always
tells me about the great investments he
makes the thing about this guy is his
investment strategy is incredibly simple
he tries out products
if he likes the products he buys the
stock and the question is does that make
sense is his investment strategy a
strategy that's going to make you a lot
of money
well jonathan your body's argument
sounds pretty convincing if we hold all
else equal all else equal a firm that
makes good products is certainly a
better investment than a firm that makes
bad products but can we hold all else
equal and as we've now seen several
times the answer to that question is
usually no we have to think this through
carefully and the thing that he's
holding all else equal is he's not
worrying about the price so holding all
else equal if i have two investments and
they cost the same i would much rather
invest with a good company than a bad
company
but as we've discussed last time you can
never hold all else equal if the company
is a particularly good company it's
going to have a high price so really
what you're interested in is not whether
the company is good or bad but whether
or not the price of the company is a
good price for a bad price
yes because overpaying for a good
company is a bad investment strategy
whereas underpaying for a bad company
will make you a lot of money going
forward so it's not just about what
you're getting but also what you're
paying for it
and so the real question is not whether
the cup is good or bad but what price
you're paying for the company
and i'd like to make the argument that
for a non-professional it's going to be
very rare or next to impossible to find
investments whose prices are attractive
or another way of saying this is it's
going to be really hard for such a
person to find good deals in the stock
market
what it's all about is about competition
and whether or not you have a
competitive advantage that you can
exploit when you're picking stocks
because if there's a good deal but
everybody already knows about it then
everybody will want to invest in it and
everybody will put in buy orders they're
going to be too many buyers and not
enough sellers and so the price will go
up and the investment opportunity will
disappear and so the only way in which
you can make money investing in good
companies between quotation marks is if
you arrive at the party early meaning
you find out that the products that the
company makes
are better
than what people thought up until that
point and so if you're the first one to
figure that out and you get into that
stock early there may still be a
possibility for you to make some extra
returns but if you're arriving at the
party at exactly the same time as
everybody else then obviously you're not
going to be making extra money and it's
not easy to arrive at that party early
and the reason is there are a lot of
people who devote their entire lives to
looking for good parties
and it's unlikely that individual
investors will have the time or the
resources
to do a better job than the people whose
career is built on
trying to arrive at the party early it's
like
a sports fan stepping onto a football
field and thinking
they can out play tom brady
it's just not a very likely event
indeed and so i mean it's not that there
are no good and bad investment decisions
in the market i think that the main
thing is
can average investors tell them apart
because to be able to tell them apart
you need to have something that other
people don't have that's exactly that
competitive advantage point and of
course by definition the average
investor doesn't have a competitive
advantage compared to everybody else
you know jules when i teach this concept
in class
i always tell an old joke which finance
professors have told for decades and the
joke goes like this a finance professor
and his student are walking down the
street and they see a hundred dollar
bill lying on the ground and the student
reaches down to pick the hundred dollar
bill up and the professor says to the
student oh don't bother if that really
was a hundred dollar bill it'll be taken
already and then i add to this joke an
addendum and the identity i add is i've
looked at my students and i say to them
how many of you have actually found a
100 bill on the ground and nobody raised
their head
nobody raises their hand
and the ensuing silence is exactly the
point which is
a if there is a hundred dollar bills
lying on the ground it's going to be
picked up very quickly so the likelihood
of you finding it
is very low and b
if you have a hundred dollar bill in
your pocket you're going to look after
it very carefully and so you're very
unlucky to drop it
so what one thing that you can add to
that though and that that really
introduces that idea of competition into
this joke is that it depends a bit on
how busy the street is if the street is
completely full of people then of course
the probability that that hundred dollar
bill will stay lying there is incredibly
low if the street is abandoned and
nobody's there then of course the
hundred dollar bill might lie there for
a bit longer although of course once it
would become known that hundred dollar
bills are lying around on this street
all the time my prediction is it will
get really busy really soon
and
also
your competitive advantage
if you happen to live on a street that's
a very quiet street and somebody dropped
a hundred dollar bill your likelihood of
picking it up is much higher than an
average person
yes absolutely another addendum to this
example which i really like to make in
class is this idea that
suppose that there is this building out
there and you are convinced that it's
full of 100 dollar bills and actually
you talk to a lot of people and a lot of
people say there are 100 bills lying in
this building all over the place and you
think to yourself
i should be going to this building
because why on earth is nobody going
there to pick up all these 100 bills you
get so overconfident you go into the
building start picking up the hundred
dollar bills the building collapses in
your debt and so in the end there was a
reason why people were actually not
going into that building to pick up
those bills it was just that you were
not realizing what the rest of the
market knew that you didn't know and you
should have thought it through better
and think why is it can i understand why
the rest of the market is not going into
that building to pick up those 100 bills
it's another all else equal mistake
right if i know there's a really good
deal out there
then all else equal i should take
advantage of the deal but everything is
not all else equal the fact that nobody
else is taking advantage of the deal
tells me that there must be something
else going on it's too easy
indeed so
jonathan how does information get into
prices right so suppose that the price
of a stock is lower than it should be
and therefore it is a good buying
opportunity so let's just say there is a
given quality for the firm but the price
of the stock is not reflecting that
quality and the price is too low
so how is that price going to
equilibrate
well i mean first of all everybody's
going to want that deal
everybody wants a good deal so people
are going to start buying that stock
at the same time somebody has to sell
that stock
if it is a good deal to buy it is a bad
deal to sell so it means not only am i
getting a good deal somebody else is
getting a bad deal and i would argue
that that's not going to last very long
they very quickly the people selling are
going to say wait a minute
i don't want to sell at such a low price
and the people buying are going to queue
up
to buy at that low price and very
quickly the price will start rising and
will keep rising until the point where
it's no longer a good deal
indeed and and the same thing of course
holds when we take the other scenario
where the price is too high and then the
price will be bid down through the same
process to arrive at the right level of
the price
and really the only way you can get a
good deal in market is you have to be
the first person who arrives and you
don't have to buy and you buy a limited
amount
and then you can make money and there
are people that do that
but they need a lot of resources
and a lot of skill to find those special
deals that nobody else sees
so the key thing then is to determine
whether or not the price is higher or
lower than where it should be
and so the question then is how do you
measure the should be
and so therefore often what we talk
about is what's called price multiples
which are relative measures of valuation
and so for different firms you can take
the ratio of the price per share to the
earnings per share of the company or you
can take the ratio of the price per
share of the company to what's called
the book value of equity which is a
measure per share of the replacement
value of the plant property equipment
and all the capital that the firm uses
to produce its products and since savvy
investors understand the all else equal
argument and understand that it's the
relative price that matters they almost
always just talk in terms of multiples
rather than in price
so let's go and talk to cliff fastness
because clefastness is an expert in
finding good deals in markets and he has
a particular approach to go about this
uh he's been very successful at it so
let's see what he has to say about this
okay well welcome classness to the show
uh we're very honored to have you
for people who don't know cliff smith is
uh manager and co-founder of aqr capital
management one of the largest
asset managers in the world and i would
say
not only that universally regarded as
one of the most successful asset
managers
in modern history you know it's really
an honor to have you here thank you
jonathan i think that's a gross
exaggeration but i enjoy gross
exaggeration so
welcome we're very happy to have you
celebrate
the objective in this particular episode
is to talk about what has commonly
become known as efficient markets the
idea that a good stock is not a good buy
it's a cheap stock that's a good buy so
with that in mind i have two questions
for you one question is a very general
question
how hard is it to find good deals in the
market but i'm going to make that very
specific because this morning when i was
brushing my teeth and i was thinking
about this interview i was thinking
about that very specifically
lots and lots of academics
go and try to do what you do
and the thing is and we know academics
are very smart but the thing is not all
of them succeed
you know what is it
that allows some people to succeed in
other people not to succeed
well first of all it's nice to know in
the era of zoom you're still brushing
your teeth
um i'm not i'm not sure all of us are
doing that you know i'm going to give
you kind of a weird answer
obviously
some people can translate the
theoretical to the practical better in
the real world trading costs and size
you can run and and uh judgments about
whether something is real or whether
it's a data mined artifact um those
those all do vary
but i'm going to give you an answer that
maybe will be a little surprising
the capacity to withstand pain
and the capacity to explain
when things are not working
why they're not working you have to be
good at what you do long term
if you could stick with it and convince
others to stick with it
i think you'd at least have a reasonably
good investment product those two things
that are often an afterthought
um
you know you being able to tolerate it
and don't think you're not your worst
client on occasion
and being able to explain it to others
you know real world investing strategies
even if you're very good
work a little more than they don't
they don't work all the time when people
you know people talk about stocks for
the long run
um in geek speak and and i'm sure your
students are familiar with these things
the stock market's like a 0.4 sharp
ratio
go simulate that in excel
it's excruciatingly hard to stick with
at times
and if anything my answer to that
question is probably pretty different
than it would have been 20 years ago i
think i appreciate that side of it
both for ourselves and for clients how
tough it is to stick with a strategy
truly everyone talks about the long term
actually being long term is a super
power in investing if you can do it it
is very hard to do
that's a very surprising answer cliff
because we spend a lot of time also in
our classroom and in our research
thinking about how to best design the
strategy but what you're saying is that
what is really an important skill is to
convince both yourself as well as your
clients to stick with the ideas that you
had and so the ability to withstand
adversity apparently is the most
important skill now we know that that's
generally true in life but apparently
that is true here in the investment
world as well
so when you're uh on the golf course you
know you always got your buddy telling
you how much money he's made in the
stock market
right let's assume they're telling the
truth
how do they do this without the
resources of aqr and you're in and all
the um
the intelligence of all the employees
you have and all of that
i think when it comes to people who are
talking to their friends on the golf
course i don't golf so i'm trying to
come up with some someplace else i i do
go to cocktail parties occasionally back
when they use the
parties um yeah you get a lot of people
talking about the stock or even the
market you know i don't think the market
is very easy to time and
you you hear a lot of opinions about
that um jonathan you said something
important you said let's assume what
they're telling you is true
a i don't always assume that but for the
sake of your argument i will
but what i won't assume is that the
people who lose terribly are as anxious
to tell their golf course stories yeah
you're so right about that people rarely
tell me how poorly they've done on their
stock picks i mean this is also one of
the reasons for why we study
when we study investment managers that
when returns are self-reported of course
the funds that did well are much more
likely to report the results than the
funds that didn't do so well so
you know by the way this this is not
different than fear of missing out fomo
on facebook you know they tell us
there's a epidemic of depressed people
because everyone thinks that other
people's lives are better than theirs uh
because they're looking at their
facebook or their instagram and all the
fun
they're they're having um you don't hear
about people's problems on facebook as
exceptions to that of course but as a
rule they're positive posts you don't
see people at cocktail parties going oh
man i suck at stock picking
let me tell you about the um you know i
made all this money but i lost it all on
these
again there are exceptions
um i i would listen to that that person
at the cocktail party they'd be kind of
fun you know the honest person who was
telling you that but that's not the rule
so you do have to be very careful of the
financial
version of fomo where your
people are cherry-picking their winners
even if they're not lying about them
and who speaks up
is being cherry-picked so i will call on
myself a cynic that the individual doing
this casually can add a whole lot of
value certainly at the concentrated
picking
of individual security
level uh but you know i made a big
concession to my efficient market roots
that i think there are some people who
clearly
can you know
when you think about we all have a golf
buddy or somebody like a golf buddy
telling us what a genius they are
one of the things that you notice when
people tell you about their investment
strategy
in a social environment is
more often than not the investment
strategy is so
clear so simple it is so clear to do
and i always think to myself
you know when these people tell me the
strategy
what makes them think that nobody else
has thought of such a simple strategy
well and also the question of who is on
the other side of that trade right i
mean this famous saying
if you don't know who the sucker is it
is probably you
yeah you know jonathan
i think you're thinking the same way but
i would sum it up as they leave price
out of their strategy
um often their strategy is about what
they think
is
going to be a big thing
you know back in 99 2000 during the
first wave of kind of tech stock mania
um people would say things like well the
internet's going to change the world
and
i think that was fairly obviously true
at the time
the notion
all right should you be paying
an infinite multiple for doctorcoop.com
he was the surgeon general who then
launched the dot com at the time there
were many other examples um the nasdaq
as a whole nasdaq 100 was selling for
about a hundred price to earnings
multiple
um
so the question you know aside from
trading trading is a whole different
world if you're trying to predict what
happens tomorrow or even the next few
months or even even the next year
that's a lot uh like warren buffett
always talks about a voting versus a
weighing machine
um that is a voting machine if other
people decide to jump on the bandwagon a
good trader doesn't necessarily need to
have a big grasp of price i i'm a little
cynical there are great natural traders
who can just feel the market also but i
don't dismiss the possibility but if
you're going to hold something as an
investor for a decent length of time
they're really
basically two things that go into it the
quality and on multi it could be
multi-dimensional quality of of the of
you know how well they execute how fast
they can grow what markets they're in
and what price you're paying to begin
with um let me tell you a story this is
from the tech bubble on 99 2000. i
remember speaking to an audience
and the audience was very cynical i'm
doing my
value has never looked
more ridiculously stretched
and there are people there somebody
raised their favorite stock i forget
which one it was but i said it was cisco
the networking stock for at least 10
years so i'm going to stick with that
though it may be a lie
and i asked them
all right
basically this question if you're going
to have to hold cisco not for a month
but for 10 20 years
and you love it i get it you love it and
we disagree
at what price
would you get out
and i was trying to induce them to
answer the question that we're groping
around
and the answer i still love the answer
thank god i don't remember who it was
because it would be very mean of me if
if if i did but the answer the person
gave me at the event
was whatever if it was selling for x
well if it dropped to half x i'd be out
it went the opposite way
and perfect uh again they might have
misunderstood i really did try to
preface it with this is a long-term hold
so basically saying if i could buy this
for the next 20 years at half the price
uh they were giving me a momentum answer
to a value question you know what i like
about that analogy is
it not only illustrates that
professionals can make all else equal
mistakes but it's another example
of where it is difficult to stick by
your guns
that the earlier points you make that
are part of the skill of a professional
is somebody who's willing to stick with
their strategy so earlier you you made a
remark which i found very interesting
which was what in in the golf course the
person who was willing to discuss their
mistakes would actually be somebody that
you would be willing to listen to and
you also seem very willing and open to
discuss the things that that have gone
poorly why do you think this is so
difficult for most people to do
well for one thing i i just think most
people haven't thought through the
strategy
um i think the world respects i i'll be
honest it's self-serving of me
i think being open and honest about
these things
the world respects it
not that i'm always respected doesn't
always work
it doesn't work each time and don't work
with each person but i think on average
uh people do sense who's bs'ing them and
who's
giving them the truth
um i do think i've gotten better at it
over my career
um it's kind of like all the people who
do sports analytics
talk about how coaches who've been
successful over the long term are
actually better coaches
not because they've learned to like what
play works but because they're
more steadfast in doing the play they
believe will work even if it's going to
get them yelled at if if it doesn't so
you you do improve upon this uh but i
think most people
they they don't quite get that if they
lead with all the things they've done
wrong
they can still impress people they can
still have people think they know what
they're doing um and this doesn't work
for everyone if you're genuinely bad at
what you're doing and you're a bit of a
boob leading with seven errors and then
never following it up with substance is
really not a good strategy
um so it does come down and maybe i'm
over endowed with this with a certain
level of self-confidence
admitting your mistakes
requires self-confidence because you
have to
you have to have faith that people will
make a judgment on the totality
not on the few things you told them that
you were stupid about
um so
i you know if i could give a life lesson
i've talked to my kids about this
that that is that is one i don't have a
lot of great life
lessons but that is certainly one
that you know if you're down the middle
about yourself and no one's perfectly
down the middle we're all a little
biased to our own story but if you're as
down the middle as you can be
have some faith in other people
uh i think it works that would work out
for many more people better than they
think not just
not just me i might have lucked into the
strategy over time i love that i think
actually there's an extension to this
which is not only do you admit your
mistakes but you learn from your stakes
i genuinely mean learn from your
mistakes i don't mean oh i made a
mistake and i repeat the same mistake
again
i really think to myself what caused me
to make that mistake
and how can i not do that again i think
it's a very difficult thing to do and i
think human beings really
struggle with that i think there's
certainly a future podcast
you know for a business decision maker
this is something we should focus on why
is it so hard to admit that you've made
a mistake
and act on it of course you're exactly
right that is the second half
admitting you've made a mistake is
lovely and it makes for for a very
cathartic conversation uh but if you
learn zero from that mistake
admitting it doesn't actually help
uh
the second part's pretty important too
um so you're right i think they often go
hand in glove i think that person
um and not just me by any means but the
person who can admit to a mistake almost
by definition is at least halfway down
the road to asking
why they made a mistake and why they
might not going forward i mean it's kind
of odd to imagine someone admitting to a
litany of mistakes
and then saying well what are you going
to do to prevent that going forward and
have them if if you have this
conversation with someone they admit a
couple of errors even though life's been
good and you go well what do you learn
from those errors and they go nothing
that would be odd i'm talking about
ex-ante errors not x post errors and
that's another one of the huge problems
right um i think x and d we launched too
aggressively
in 1998 at aqr
x post we got one of the most savage
value drawdowns again the next three
years was wonderful so i'll always throw
that in the marketing hat has to go on
um but that was x post
but i do think we made an ex ante
mistake there is also if i can be
a little crass about it
uh and someone at aqr is going to yell
at me for this
our legal
world
has people terrified to say the words i
made a
mistake um
every and they're doing their jobs and
they're wonderful people at least the
ones at our firm i actually like our
legal and compliance people
but they never
i scare them
when i when i say things like yeah i
think we got that one wrong
and they're like you can't say that i'm
like
does anyone think we get everything
right is there anyone on earth who
thinks that
my mother didn't think that um and she
was biased towards me
so i think that part of our culture
and it doesn't mean it's a net negative
um there's a lot of legal protections we
have and it does protect the world from
some things but that part of the culture
also pushes any corporate
executive
away from the words yeah we were wrong
about that one our bad so yeah one of
the reasons why we decided to do the
podcast to begin with is because people
make mistakes all the time and it is
very difficult to learn from them and so
you really need to talk them through and
see the commonalities and the mistakes
that people are making so thank you so
much cliff for spending the time with us
it's been really great and it's been a
lot of fun too no it has been fun thank
you guys
thanks everybody for listening we hope
you enjoyed the podcast in the interview
with cliff asness we learned a lot from
him certainly what he explained was that
not putting price into the equation is
gonna make you make a mistake i think
that came through very clearly but i was
surprised with the fact that the most
important investment management skill
was to stick with it and to stick
through it i hadn't expected that to be
the answer to the question what is the
skill and shortest supply so now next
time we're going to apply the same all
else equal logic to money management
so should you put your money with the
best manager and best manager said a
five-star rated manager by morningstar
if you put your money with that manager
are you going to get high returns going
forward yes or no that's what we're
exploring next time and the guest we
have for that is pete brieger who is a
ceo of the fortress investment group one
of the largest global investment
managers
thanks for listening to all else equal
podcast please leave us a review at
apple podcast we love to hear from our
listeners
and be sure to catch our next episode by
subscribing or following our show
wherever you listen to your podcasts
for more information and episodes visit
allelepodcast.com
or follow us on linkedin the all else
equal podcast is a joint venture of
stanford university's graduate school of
business and the wharton school at the
university of pennsylvania and has
produced a podium podcast
[Music]
you